foreign
foreign foreign
are now establishing a message and our
Center to enhance the Norwegian dower if
you donate to the schools you will
ensure Allah reap the rewards of
thousands of Muslims coming back to
Islam and many of those who become
Dwight and invite Islam so click the
link and donate now and share the video
for extra Rewards
and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the Dunya the three Muslims today
we're joined with the usual host brother
fayad we're missing one but he will be
here shortly inshallah how you doing
fired
how are you alhamdulillah I'm doing good
you know when I the video we're going to
talk about on the video we're going to
react to today when I first saw it I was
obviously I think like a lot of people
very mad I was very upset but I don't
think that's going to be the vibe of the
stream inshallah I don't think we should
you know come off very harshly or
strongly nor do I think that we will
inshallah because the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam he said the best of us
are those who have the best of character
so yes we're upset
we don't like certain things that some
people say but you know those emotions
don't always justify harsh reactions or
insults so throughout the stream
inshaallah we will not be insulting
Logan Paul nor do I think we should and
I don't want to see anyone commenting
disrespectful things as I've seen people
already starting to do that so inshallah
don't do that because we represent Islam
we are Muslims alhamdulillah and let's
keep it from the for the sake of Allah
I mean bro now before brother Angel
comes on do you want to give a brief
description about what we're going to be
going into and to the viewers quick PST
guys stay tuned we got one of the
biggest guests we have ever had on the
channel inshallah there's going to be a
huge podcast in March 2023 inshallah we
can't we've been advised maybe legally
maybe PR wise I don't know but we've
been advised not to mention who it is so
we're not allowed to mention who it's
going to be but
biggest guest you can imagine in sha
Allah this is going to be huge March
2023 stay hyped inshallah this is um
this is one guest
um or one guest ah bro listen We're Not
Gonna We're Not Gonna confirm nor deny
that but
inshallah we can get uh Dr Zucker hell
no bro
you can't have a normal conversation
stuff for Halloween bro it would be like
30 seconds and then you'd probably fall
asleep for a guy
yeah but alhamdulillah everything's
confirmed
um we're not going to mention anything
else inshallah this will be filmed
internationally so please get hyped and
stay tuned for that
beautiful announcement so um what to
expect from this video you're going to
see Logan Paul engage in a discussion
with his friend uh George I'm not gonna
play the full thing there are many other
instances in the podcast where it was a
little bit shallow from Logan to say
certain things
um you're going to see that inshallah
you know some of it but we're not going
to include all of it I mainly want to
include the religious stuff because you
know as Muslims alhamdulillah
um we don't have to deal with a lot of
these you know problems problems people
put forth in the name of religion
because people like Logan you know
atheists whatever they love to put
religions under one banner and just deem
them all you know crazy or backwards or
you know extreme and all these things
but this is a uh this is a just a very
easy scapegoat for them to get away from
the problem of religion and having to
deal with it they don't want to have to
intellectually deal with religion and
the idea of God and they can't actually
intellectually deal with the Rel with
the idea of religion and God there's no
logical basis to disagree with the idea
of God there's no logical basis to
disagree with the idea of religion so
what do they do oh look what this group
over there did look what that religious
group look at there's every religion has
a religious group that does crazy things
all religions must be bad and it's just
a very easy way to have to not deal with
it and we see he does that with Jordy
and he actually puts these terms onto
his own friend but without further ado
we have our brother here angels
I mean I told the viewers that we got a
huge guest coming up March 2023
not who it is but that's all they're
gonna know and I'm sure what did you
think when you when you first basically
got the confirmation from us
um
somebody yelling at me
uh I was amazed bro but then again like
I don't know the more the more we I
can't even speak bro the the longer I'm
a Muslim
nothing really is a surprise anymore you
know
okay and then Rami gave a little bit of
a disclaimer to everyone that we're not
trying to entice any type of harassment
or bullying towards Logan Paul
none of that all right he's already kind
of
created somewhat of a controversial
reputation himself so we really don't
have to do much anyway
um we're here to dissect some of the
clips and I say we we go in without
further Ado all right I'm just gonna add
the video
destroy families bro it destroys
countries it destroys the world of his
argument exactly so but I'm fighting for
everybody and so I really did get hurt
when we're joking around you're like oh
yeah you believe in uh Christians and
and uh uh they they hate gays and that
crushed me because there's a lot of
people that I love
that are gay so when you put me in that
box I'm like bro I am the farthest
friend I ain't putting you in any box
you are putting yourself in that box no
yes you are can I ask you something can
I ask you something okay there's a mass
shooting a white guy does it do I look
at you and be like all white people are
on the fence to go do a mass shooting no
I don't put you it wasn't my decision to
be white so that argument's irrelevant I
want to say was you I would have said
atheist it was yours it was your
decision
okay so I want to pause it just right
there to to jump into it you can see
it's already hectic to begin with you
know and you could tell there's there
have been a lot of previous discussions
between George and Logan on the topic of
religion all that stuff and I think it's
killed that George is just a little bit
fed up like you're constantly putting me
in this box calling me these names
calling me these things unfortunately
religious people actually experience
this a lot you know especially when
people don't want to actually you know
intellectually engage with you on the
subject matter of religion they will
just put you in a box actually it
happens in politics as you know as well
you know you're just a liberal you're
just a libtard you're just uh this stuff
the other they love to throw people in
the boxes so they don't have to you know
actually engage with you and deal with
these
um intellectual answers that some
religious people give so
but I like what Mike added at the end
with the whole discussion
because
Logan made the argument that listen
I didn't choose to be white you chose to
be a Christian
it's not the same Mike said what he said
a better argument's an atheist
because Stalin was an atheist he did
horrible things
you know what about the the Western
people who colonize our land and did
Terrible Things he's a Westerner his
parents are probably westerners he's
probably you know born from a European
family we don't look at him and say oh
you guys did this you guys did that
you're all the same
and again he would say oh I didn't
choose to be XYZ but
buy yourself a nice cap actually my my
man I'm I'm ahead of you so thank you
but regardless you can you can argue and
I'm willing to argue this even on even
on the behalf of Christians I would say
that Christians don't actually choose to
be a Christian what do I mean by that if
a Christian genuinely believes that
Christianity is the truth
you don't you don't choose what the
truth is
they believe it's the truth I don't
think it is they believe it's the truth
they're not choosing what the truth is
they believe it's truth so they accept
it
same thing with you being an atheist you
think God does not exist therefore
you're not an atheist am I going to link
you up buddy buddy with Stalin that
wouldn't be fair same thing with us
being Muslim we didn't choose to be
Muslim in the sense that uh we're making
up a reality now we genuinely believe
Islam is the truth we want to do what is
best for us in our life and worship God
and submit to him therefore we are
Muslim so you can even argue that
religious people don't really choose to
be religious but that's just what you
know the arbitrator of Truth has
dictated what do you guys think of that
in the clip that we just saw so far
I just want to watch the rest of it bro
all right before I formulate an opinion
a lot of people that have different
religions but my point is I'm not
running to label you bro I would rather
want to sit and understand you and learn
from you than judge you and put you in a
box there's also a lot of denominations
that have come around to the idea of
homosexuality I think I think that
exactly that's stating that Christianity
in general is a homosexuality hating
religion is a is a is like a blanket
statement that does not cover the
entirety of the truth well also it's not
true because if you do not love thy
neighbor and that means gay or straight
then you are not a child of God that is
literally quoted in the Bible yeah but
what about conversion therapy like what
what is conversion therapy something
your church does stop saying my church
bro I don't know what it's something but
it's also something like that but it's
also something yeah what's my church
name I don't know exactly but you do
this in the church that practices
Christianity these are blankets is it a
church yes or no yes but the church that
church runs conversion therapy
so does atheists
atheist Church no it doesn't mean
conversion therapy is not a
church-sponsored exercise it's a science
I don't have this stat but I would argue
that there is a probably a higher
concentration of conversion therapy
classes or courses whatever the [ __ ]
they are in Christian churches I would
like to see the stats to back actually
both of you guys are completely wrong
there's religions that will put them to
death no no no because what I'm saying
is I my my argument would be that the
majority of conversion therapy happens
as a result of Parental uh
recommendations that are not bad that
are not necessarily backed in religion
or anything besides the fact that the
parents don't want their kids to be uh
transitioning into something that they
believe that or not and a general also
like
this is there's so many different
factors and so many different situations
here
the way the way things are delivered is
a massive thing Logan as you said
earlier notoriously and I and I've
stated this to him he knows this has one
of the worst deliveries ever when it
comes to criticism when it comes to
talking about things he's a big swinging
egotistical [ __ ] in arguments and that's
a fact do you want to know why that's a
fact
you know you bashed me you attack my
character no I haven't no no I said I
haven't I'm not saying anybody who said
it what I'm saying is in arguments you
you do you say you call it yourself you
say I like to pull out my swords and you
[ __ ] people up you slash and dice you
you caught yeah it comes in good A lot
of people comes right well listen it's
not always con it's not always
productive for a conversation that has
such intellectual uh variance and so
many factors when you put someone
against the fence a lot of times it
changes their their confidence their
understanding real conversation that
drives productive conversation and
productive debate is is conf is should
be comfortable in nature that takes
place in a respectful that I say makes
you uncomfortable because of the
substance of the sentence it's not that
that is you're not the substance what is
it the delivery
it doesn't matter yeah usually others
how you want to be treated
rationality it's your delivery whatever
you speak let me speak because I I don't
want anybody to get upset while I
definitely agree with you we've we've
talked and you are right and my my
delivery
is something else very hard yes
treat others how you want to be treated
right yeah but nobody wants it I don't
want to be babied bro I don't want to be
baby no but some people aren't I don't
like it because it turns out it's not
true everyone wants to be coddled into
the truth everyone wants to be handheld
and walked up the mountain with a buddy
instead of climbing it themselves but
what about what you want I don't [ __ ]
with that what about what you want out
of the conversation like and I've had
this conversation I've had this talk
with you a million times what if the
intent is for you to get a productive
response from the person across from you
yeah so so when you say you want you
don't want to be babied what if you want
them to produce the most meaningful and
effective argument that they can so so
that you can have the best and most
productive conversation and if I tell
you that your approach and your delivery
is hindering their ability to produce an
effective argument would that change
your approach in a work environment
absolutely and and I will coddle in a
work environment if I need something
from Heaven that is like a serious
sticking point
I will gather myself before I have the
conversation take a deep breath and try
to convey the information in a way that
it's going to most suit Kevin
and that's even a new thing for you
because of you no because of you because
you in a work environment fine but if
I'm talking about religion with someone
who I love sorry bro I love you so I'm
gonna be harsh as [ __ ] with you I ain't
holding back anything I'm bringing out
my swords same with you and you know
that I mean you were fine oh I love I
love you guys I love you guys so I'm
gonna attack you to the [ __ ] hardest
100 that's how that's just how I am in
my life because I know that that veil of
love will never go away I have a I have
a question I want to read this
um because we're speaking about love and
we I did not know we were about to talk
about this I swear on everything
okay so before they go on we're almost
at the halfway point sorry if I if I had
to move I was just gonna say deposit two
bro perfect yeah yeah sorry I apologize
for the uh the cussing that was my fault
I forgot to remove the um the swear
words so forgive me for that but
uh yeah what do you guys think so far
it's a lot of yelling huh
that's not to make quick announcement
bro just to the viewers we got so many
announcements today before we go right
into this
um we have a brother that will be
alhamdulillah joining Islam today taking
the Shadow with us um so we're gonna put
that towards the end of the stream make
sure you guys stay tuned till the end of
this stream this is live by the way
um for the inshallah but pertaining to
you know what we heard so far
I don't know this guy much compared to
you know the other two co-hosts George
and the other brother but what they're
saying you know
I'm not here trying to argue with Logan
Paul or agree with him or disagree with
him my point is the substance behind
what people say now for me I care about
those that are around me so I kind of
don't want them having their eyes closed
all the time and I do want to tell them
the truth
but now there's a way to say it there's
an emotionally intelligent way to say it
and then there's a way to say it just to
you know act controversial there's a lot
of YouTubers you guys know who I'm
talking about I'm not gonna name any
names but people that just try to act
harsh and controversial and blunt and
aggressive for no reason if I gotta say
what needs to be said I'll say it but
there's a way to say it
yeah 100 I don't know how Broadway you
man you've been silent but you've been
very loud with your movements
he reminds me a lot of myself before
Islam
how something when my ego was uh very
very
big
because the way he speaks is it's not
emotionally intelligent it's it's almost
like emotionally [ __ ] and I only say
that because that's that's how I was
before you know I was like if I saw
something I wanted to convey exactly how
it was truthfully I didn't want to
sugarcoat it I didn't wanna
Mega PG-13
block anything I want to say it exactly
how it was I didn't care if I was
hurting their feelings or what and I
used to say the same thing oh if you got
a problem with it like it's that's on
you that's on you man like I'm just
telling you the truth
but it's like fire said
there's emotional intelligence and you
have to understand that everyone
is going through their own thing in
their own life and it's not about
coddling them it's about understanding
where they are emotionally where they
are intellectually where they are in
their life right now what can they
receive what can they not receive
you know so it's like when you when you
understand that then you understand the
words to say that are either going to
disarm someone or that are going to arm
the person
so again it's like you can still say the
truth but
you got to put your ego aside man like
what makes you think what makes you
think that what you're saying is like
is it you know you learn one little
thing and then out of nowhere you want
to just attack someone and say it in
such a way that it's you're slashing
them come on bro yeah come on bro and
you know um the the funny part is right
before this clip I didn't include it
because I thought that this segment
would be more productive but right
before this clip Logan
um George brought up the fact that Logan
said he needs he needs uh therapy
because because he believes in Jesus and
um and all that stuff then as the
conversation progressed Logan said you
you need a therapist because Jesus isn't
doing it for you and then George is like
okay in what aspect of my mental state
do I need a therapist for and Logan said
your lack of emotional intelligence so
it's really funny because you know it's
I and Angela as far as I know you
haven't seen that clip you didn't see my
the little short video I made on it you
just came to that conclusion on your own
just from watching you know his this one
clip you don't know that Logan called
Joe George you know emotional
intelligent you buy yourself a
conclusion that Logan's actually
emotional intelligent and I think that
that speaks volumes because George
himself says I think on the emotionally
most emotionally intelligent here and I
would agree with that you know based on
this conversation other conversations he
had I think that he is the most
emotional intelligence now
I want this to be beneficial for people
so I want to kind of Define what
emotional intelligence is
with four kind of you know
four
what what you know it looks like this is
the four things that basically emotional
intelligence encompasses foreign
yeah yeah this place thank you or traits
of someone who's emotionally intelligent
one is that a person can
um recognize emotion
so they could see this person inside mad
happy whatever then you take it a step
further that now not only do they
recognize it but they understand it oh
they're upset because of this and it
could be something subtle you know but
they recognize it regardless women are
very very good at this and George I
think is good at it um as well as they
mentioned himself
third and this is hard is that you
regulate and control your own emotions
probably one of the most difficult ones
because it has to do with self-restraint
and the last one
is you use emotion to positively impact
people that you use whatever they're
feeling to motivate them to be better
and to do better
that's what emotional intelligence is I
think religious people
are tremendously good at this generally
I think religious people are
tremendously tremendously good at this
because they have an aspect of
humanitarianism that I'd say atheists
lack
because atheism leads to moral nihilism
they can't prove anything morally which
segues into my next point
you know Logan's willing to drop all
these huge names this phobic
misogynistic all these crazy names onto
his co-host without having ever having
an objective basis for what he's saying
to begin with
you know anything
sorry oh no go on bro I don't want to go
on forever no no no I'm just I'm gonna
say he's he's very passionate and that's
not a bad thing but in his situation
it's blinding him
and it's uh making an egg and speak and
uh do things in certain ways which yeah
you know if he was more level-headed he
wouldn't do that yeah you know like you
can get your message across
you don't you're not again you're not
like fully fully filtering yourself you
can say what you have to say because
y'all can agree with me when I say that
I don't exactly filter myself a hundred
percent like sometimes I might say
something on the Old Dan like did I
really say that and I'll even say like
yo like forgive me I didn't mean to say
that that sounded like really that
sounded really bad after like I thought
about it you know but it's it's again
it's understanding where this person is
and then it's also understanding that
you don't have to argue all the time
you don't have to debate all the time
you can speak about things in a very
calm demeanor and nine times out of ten
you're gonna get a lot further when you
do speak about things in a you know in a
calm grounded way and then also bro like
in my own experience whenever I was this
blunt with people it it never actually
created connections with them if
anything it created a disconnection it
created it was like I was Burning
Bridges with people that I hadn't even
like formed the bridge to begin with
yeah
absolutely 100 I think that's actually a
really good way to summarize the you
know emotional perspective of it and how
he carries himself uh and I I second
that 100 if I do have anything to add
before we continue yeah there was a
starter thing I wanted to address bro if
you wanted to answer that he said lack
of monster intelligence because George
stormed out in a podcast yeah but
actually if you watch that podcast that
was in my opinion the most emotionally
intelligent thing he could have done
because I'm pretty sure Bobby Lee who
was the guest on the show made a joke
about something that George was really
emotionally affected by and it hurt him
and you can see and I think he actually
made note that this is something that
hurts him and I think Bobby continued so
he just walked off you call it storming
off whatever and later after that
um George mentions that he spoke to
Logan about this before you know if
something happens it's okay if I you
know walk off and Logan said yes Mike
even concurred and it wasn't an issue so
you know all three of them don't
actually have a problem with it and I
think again it was just an excuse to
back Logan's
um statements he didn't want to
contradict himself I think it does have
a lot to do with ego and I I genuinely
think he's just losing the plot honestly
I think he's letting his Eagle get the
best of him and um
I think he puts himself too high
honestly speaking like emotionally
speaking emotionally speaking I think he
has too much of a regard for himself and
he's just like it's sad to say he just
thinks he's right um without actually
investigating whether he is or is it
um inshallah
but this morning when we were going back
and forth I want to read what we were
talking about and I said I I said I
would do anything uh dodging the Matrix
and I go anything basically I said I'll
do anything for you to see God I would
love that I would love for you to see
God when we're going back and forth on
it and
I basically talk about how I would get
rid of everything that I love for you to
see God and you said would you even get
rid of Belle and I said on a serious
note sorry if if God came to me and said
the only way that Logan would ever see
me is if you suffer a life of loneliness
I said I would take it and you said wow
that is love and it was the first line I
screenshotted that because it was the
first time me and you met common ground
with love what do you mean I love you
George just because I don't believe in
what you believe in doesn't mean I love
I don't I get it I get it but you do you
do like this [ __ ] where if you don't
agree with it like we'll be talking
about something over here and they'd be
like nah because you hate gays and I'm
like what the [ __ ] bro I was like and
and bro and I can't tell over text if
you're being serious that's another big
problem so like that's another big
problem like like no is is our satire
and our our conversation because because
dude I'm gonna be honest with you so
when you guys started getting into it
today in this little scrap in the group
chat which by the way fired up quite a
bit I think you call them disgusting
which so I so I hit up I said he was
[ __ ] all night more time to pray so
he said I said guys I don't know if I
can do the podcast I've been shooting so
much and he goes extra time for you to
pray
that's funny to me
dude I'm giggling in the car laughing at
it
and George said that's disgusting and it
is disgusting like all they said back
was haha what did I say when we texted
by herself you call me stupid as [ __ ] no
I did it I said that I said I'm
disgusted of your uh lack of disrespect
and intelligence yes and then I said
intelligence
you know why because I realize he comes
after Jesus I'm coming after his
intelligence it's the two things that we
love the most you love your intelligence
more than I love my jeans no but that
was what makes me intelligent is I'm not
falling for the myth no it's not a myth
listen buddy you know it's a myth you
thinking you're smart that's a myth but
nobody believes that myth here I don't
think I'm smart George I think you're an
amazingly Superman no no no you know I'm
gonna I won't say amazing but I'm smart
I'm objectively smart you're a genius
and no matter how you cut it so yes I
thought that's why that was funny
exactly you said lack of disrespect fine
you're right I was being disrespectful
no no but intelligence or lack of
respect I was being disrespectful but
lack of of intelligence that deserves a
little ha ha ha come on what are you
talking about could you shake my hand
and move forward with these
conversations with love
well what can I connect can I put it but
it is all love it is all love you're
you're your interpretation of my love is
not how how I'm dishing it out no it's
you know and I will admit half of it is
my fault because I'm not like Mike I
can't just like stand up to be like yo
shut the [ __ ] up because I love you so
much that I'm scared if I get mad at you
with this situation then you'll really
hate God and so I get really nervous I
talk out of love all the time until I
want to [ __ ] strangle you and then
make you me God you know
I love you hey hey the fastest way have
you thought about that yes many times
Caleb he'll meet him yeah yeah if if I
was ever going to kill a human being now
this is a joke but I feel like
somebody's gonna take it for real like
No One's Gonna no one's
hey hey by the way when you when I
texted Levin so this is where things get
[ __ ] up
Jeff Levin yeah Jeff Levin yeah so I
sent him I text him I said yo you oh he
texted me he said yo it's George serious
right now about what group chat when you
guys were like going at it calling each
other and [ __ ] and I said yeah bro and
he said last week George said to me
Jeff you're evil Kanye was right about
you
and he said and he said no listen and he
said and this is a really interesting
point bro no it's not all roasting each
other and I said you know what Kanye
West was right about it
when I wrote to you it's just a rose no
no no no because then you guys need to
know about time and place because if
we're sitting down having an actual
honest like listen if somebody just came
up to me and was like hey uh my grandpa
just died and you say hey go [ __ ] your
grandpa that's that timing and by the
way you'll be like no one would ever do
that Logan did that and by the way I had
more deaths this year than I've ever
experienced in my life but I know that's
how you deal with comedy you don't see
me being like drama trauma trauma trauma
bro it's a joke I said a joke obviously
I love Jews my superhero Jesus Christ is
a Jew if I could be a Jew right now I
would be a Jew did anybody think that
Kanye was gonna become a Nazi I feel
like Dan was such a that was a curveball
that was because he was like you know
what I'm saying like bro he was so chill
with like because he was on the other
side where he was like George Bush does
not love black people you know and like
saying some [ __ ] on that side and for
him to just become a Nazi bro or just be
chilling with Nazis I didn't know I
didn't see it coming and the way that he
said he loved Hitler with that many O's
of varying capitalization I know he said
I love
Hitler oh no there's a lot of things
that I I I knew it wasn't going down the
right path when he came out with that
album
um with like Jesus it was like Jesus
and don't finish that line
uh and I ain't saying she a gold digger
no I'm just gonna start saying a lot of
words I'm not supposed to say on the
show it was like a church thing and it
was like yo come with us we're gonna
we're gonna go to church and I was so
excited so all my friends from Arizona
came and we went
um and bro it wasn't church it was a
concert everybody was getting super
drunk out there look Jesus and they were
drinking see but I didn't I didn't judge
them I was just like oh this isn't for
me but bro but the Lord said another
issue I have is
foreign
y'all can do whatever you want and then
just ask for forgiveness and you're
chilling yes yes
all right bro listen listen it's so hard
for me listen let me just bro it's very
hard for me to not
pause it
and say this because it needs to be said
like I was trying really hard just to
like listen to this but I don't even
need to hear the rest of it bro it's not
y'all like y'all religious people or
anyone like that it's just Christianity
we don't believe we can do whatever we
want and repent and it'll be we'll be
chilling and there's no responsibility
no accountability in this life we don't
we don't just believe and will be saved
yeah I mean it depends on the situation
you know if I if I um if I mess up and
you know like forget to pray my solar or
something you know I or I commit a sin
just against myself I can ask Allah to
forgive me but it's the way he phrased
it is like you know deliberately you
know having this kind of misdemeanor or
deliberately like you know harming
somebody and it's like oh I can just
repent and yeah there are some
denominations of Christianity that have
that issue with oh all I need to do is
believe so oh if you kill somebody go to
heaven yeah
for them they have the issue but um yeah
he's you see how he just he throws forth
this accusation that may not actually
Encompass what George believes and he
does it multiple times and says well you
believe this and he he says himself no I
don't he's like well your religion does
it's like okay but what like what does
that mean which denomination of his
religion just talk to the guy I actually
think George is a very nice person based
off you know what he said and something
he said about as a side note resonated
with me very much he's like I don't want
you to hate God because of me so I'm not
going to be rude I'm not gonna that's so
beautiful man that's so beautiful the
may Allah got him to this time because
that's that's a beautiful thing to have
but like I and people might be wondering
you know why am I saying why why am I
saying what I'm about to say you know
what I said in the past what I'm about
to say because I want this to be a
learning point for everyone and I
genuinely hope that Logan sees this
reflects on his own Insha'Allah and just
becomes a better person
this is he I think he's made it clear
that he's like almost living in his own
world he's like very very arrogant he's
very arrogant even to the point where
like he will use things in such a wrong
way like treat others how you want to be
treated is something we that person
applies to himself to make the other
person feel better
it's something that I apply to myself to
make you feel better it's not something
where I justify acting like a arrogant
egotistical you know angry person and
say why are you not returning the same
energy give it back to me
that's not how you use the phrase that's
not how they that's not what they taught
you in elementary school Logan
so you don't twist things to try and fit
things you know positions you already
have
that's it's just there's no commonality
between people like that everyone's
going to be living in their own world in
that way
and
I'll let you guys inshallah jump in I
know he they said a lot of like blah
blah in the middle there but it does get
back to religion I think in a bit yeah I
wanted to hit this point where you were
saying that
you don't
you had mentioned the point where he was
like oh I don't want you to hate God
because of me
and that you said like you know you you
tend to think the same way sometimes
with
um pretty sure that your actions and
when you deal with people and stuff like
this
uh before he was saying that I was
thinking to myself you know what it's
actually kind of his fault that Logan is
disrespecting him in this way and that
so-and-so friends in this group chat are
disrespecting him in a certain way and
making certain jokes that are
uh basically getting to him for like a
better words and then the moment he said
that when he was like oh like I don't
want God I don't want you to hate God
because of me it's like well you could
see it that way
or you could see it as like look you set
firm boundaries
and because you sit from boundaries now
this person knows
like look this is what so-and-so person
of so-and-so religion is like they
actually set firm boundaries you know so
you're setting an example versus me
basically acting like a [ __ ] I'm sorry
to say it like that but I'm gonna act
like that and then I'm gonna let you
disrespect me I'm gonna let you
disrespect my religion
and then I'm gonna get emotional about
it why would I do this
if if I was atheist right
and I'm over here saying something
disrespectful to someone who is a Muslim
if they start laughing and what I just
said that's ammo for me bro I'm gonna
keep going I'm gonna keep disrespecting
them all I know that there is no line
there and I can cross even further in
and then once they have a response then
when they get a little upset then I know
oh I can't go further than this because
I know I've I've gone a little too far
now but if they would have been from the
beginning if I would have said something
disrespectful and they would be like hey
uh we can joke around about a lot of
things but I'm gonna tell you right now
my religion this is not something that I
joke around about
and if I would be like oh bro like it's
just religion like children a lot and
then he says like no no no no
like I don't care what you think I don't
care how you feel
like my religion is not something we
joke around about if you can respect
that we can continue talking if not then
we can cut the conversation right here
bro I would respect that
and then Not only would I respect his
religion but I would also respecting on
so many other accounts that I wouldn't
even maybe have had those conversations
with him yet but I'll know okay he if he
has a boundary here then he definitely
has a clear boundary over there and over
there and over there so I got to be more
respectful and uh hold myself more
accordingly when I speak to him
yeah that's a very good form though
that's a really good point I didn't
think about it like that because I was
thinking about the more like you know
being nice good character side but I
think you are absolutely right about
that if he's continuing to step on your
toes and deliberately saying things like
he's been saying on this podcast I think
absolutely right yeah and let me let me
pause for a second because this is me
being hush and then this is me thinking
about it and being like whoa I gotta I
gotta be a little more emotional
intelligent this is not me calling him a
[ __ ] this is just me saying like if you
can't stand for what you believe in
in a
assertive way not in uh basically a
belittling way where you're putting
another person down or you're like just
really angry about it but in this in an
assertive grounded way well then that's
it's not very good is it weak
so again I'm not saying that that's what
he is but his actions are reflections of
that absolutely
very well said it's uh it reminds me of
this video that you know I saw about
this YouTuber I'm not going to mention
who I don't think they're Muslim but the
title basically said it's your fault if
they disrespect you
now initially before I watched this
video I think Arnold knows the YouTuber
I'm talking about before we watch this
video I was like you know what bro
that's that's so mean
you know that's so that's that that's
not nice yeah I know and I was like bro
how could someone say that like it's
your fault if you get disrespected and
then when I actually watch that video
and understood the context it was like
basically the amount of respect that you
demand and require from other people and
and obviously vice versa you give that
to other people that's how much you're
gonna get and if you're out here just
being whatever angel said just being
soft being a pushover then you know
whose fault is it other than yours
yeah let me tell you all a story all
right let me tell you a story
uh one time
I got picked up by uh my two friends
and we were gonna go to the gun range
and I was sitting in the back of my
friend's truck and then my friend in the
front
he started like popping off like saying
random jokes we were laughing
and uh meanwhile keep in mind I'm Muslim
at the time I think I'm like maybe a
year or something into being Muslim
and so first he started saying um jokes
about like Indians
and I was like okay I couldn't help but
laugh because of the things he was
saying
and then he started saying something
about Jews and like I'm not gonna lie it
was it was funny but I could notice like
he's he's starting to get like really
disrespectful so I'm like ah let me kind
of hold myself back a little bit because
like why would I laugh at something
that's like disrespecting another
person's religion
the person the friend who's driving is
Jew or he was Jew at least now he's
Christian supposedly and um the one
who's making the jokes well he's uh I
guess you could say agnostic right it
doesn't really pertain himself to any
religion then he said something
about Islam
and the moment he said something about
Islam they started laughing and like I
immediately just like someone was like
whoa
and they had like the music on I was
like turn the music off
you turn the music off and then they
tried to keep talking I was like no no
no no no no
let me bring it back for a second
I Islam you don't joke about Islam
and he's like oh bro like effing chill
out like we were just talking about Jews
and Indians I was like listen
I don't care what you were talking about
I don't care if we're joking around
about anything here
Islam
you don't joke about Islam
and if you can if you can't deal with
that
y'all could drop me off at home
and bro from there you could tell he was
upset
but he didn't say anything else
from there bro so again it's just it's
it's placing a clear boundary in a
respectful way where again if it's
assertive people are going to respect
that and if if they still cross it well
then
you do what you got to do you know you
you have to enforce the boundary you
have to enforce the consequences if
something does pop up so it's just just
a story to like drive it home
for y'all absolutely a lot more about it
bro
I mean
anything else we have one Super Chat
yeah we have actually two super chats so
we can put them up
um and to anyone that made it here guys
please stick to the end we got a live
shahada insha Allah with a beautiful
brother that wants to convert to Islam
inshallah so he will do it live with us
make sure you guys don't leave
I'll try to bring them both up so the
first one
is this one
learning about stem has saved my life I
appreciate what you guys do Allah I'm
Filipino and was learning my history and
found out the Philippines has a deep
Muslim history
that's beautiful
uh shazub says Logan Paul's zero
theistic knowledge but speaks like he is
academically qualified on the issue
extremely arrogant that's another thing
I'll talk about it maybe later on if
someone reminded me if I forget atheists
have a deep sense of intellectual and
logical arrogance
bro you know what that reminds me of
y'all ever heard the saying where it's
like
when someone speaks a lot they only
review how little they know yeah and
usually usually it's the person that's
like most quiet
that's like the wisest and has the most
knowledge because the more you know the
less you say and the less you know the
more you say
yes but not that's not nothing against
you bro
you're saying the The Beneficial
knowledge but you get what I'm saying
bro absolutely 100 100
oh
so what what
you got a problem with that okay no
actually that's actually a myth that's
not true oh what can't be forgiven uh
blasphemy of the holy spirit is like oh
my God the one thing you did so me
saying that Jesus oh my God uh no
because he says anything that is said to
the father will be forgiven anything for
the uh for the Holy Spirit would be not
forget which one which one is the Holy
Spirit the father son of the holy spirit
so the holy spirit's in all of us so I
can't say the Holy Spirit [ __ ] I I
wouldn't I'll tread lightly but also
here's the thing bro like God's not
sitting there wanting you to be judged
he's not he's not looking at you like I
can't wait till you mess up so I could
burn you bro like he's the Bible isn't
anything for you to worship him it's for
you to live a peaceful better life is it
arrogant
to assume that
God gives a [ __ ]
about me or you well I feel like
everybody wants to be loved and to be
loved by somebody you know it's arrogant
to think your dad loves you
well his dad doesn't love him so that's
a good point I'm just kidding GP loves
you so much by the way yeah yeah yeah so
much you know what we even have the most
beautiful conversations which is so
astonishing to me because we could get
deep me and him bro we'll sit on the
phone for an hour or two that's odd
don't touch the pillow I was using that
you know what I said to Logan yesterday
and the and my final note on this whole
religious take
if George is wrong he goes to the same
place as you
but if you're wrong I'm not oh he said
that he said that I said I'm just not I
said
but if you are on some strange chance
you are gonna have to wake up
first of all burning in hell every day
and I don't even know that you'll be
able to sleep because imagine think
about it for a second bro but whatever
like bro let me know but what's burning
everything everything no what is it me
nope it wasn't my energy no I don't know
what is it don't worry about that but
here's the part is it me at this age
there's the party is it me at the age I
die when a baby dies do they go to
heaven or hell uh it's innocent so again
I'm gonna say the same answer no one
knows who goes to heaven or hell but the
father
if a baby murdered someone does the baby
go to heaven or hell oh who did he
murder
again same answer I don't know who goes
to heaven or hell bro and nobody does
and anybody who tells you they have the
answers to who goes to heaven and hell
sway ain't got the answers I know that
for sure
um but he did he actually admitted that
oh he did sway did have the [ __ ]
answers that's what was the [ __ ] up
thing about as much as this conversation
is uncomfortable I'm very proud of us
and I'll tell you why because nobody
else would have the balls to have these
type of conversations out there are you
uncomfortable no excuse me bro why does
this man sound like an agent of the
Matrix bro
that's what everyone keeps saying um
he's because he's just repeating the
same like you know critically a
politically correct opinion but like my
my friend quoted this to me once and it
was in regards to Jordan Peterson
talking with Muhammad hijab you know
when Muhammad asked him if if if you get
you know logical or rational
intellectual evidence and proof that
Islam is the truth will you accept it
and he started or like if you get uh
proof that God exists or
actually no sorry he asked you believe
in God and he Jordan Peterson asked what
do you mean by do what do you mean by
you what do you mean by believer what do
you mean by God and I'm like that's so
like the definition of God I can
understand that one is definitely mean
by God okay that's fair
you need me to define the word do excuse
me are you serious and my friend he he I
remember this this thing he said one in
doubt create ambiguity that's exactly
what Logan did he was in doubt he didn't
want to have to deal with these
intellectual questions that were coming
his way so he just created more
ambiguity what's burning how old am I
what number does it matter what's
burning and how old you are if you're
burning are you really gonna be like oh
my God I'm burning with with red walls
ow no it doesn't matter what's burning
around you bro and the whole thing about
if if a baby commits murder
a baby doesn't have the capacity to even
commit murder like why would you ask
such a silly question
a murder is a premeditated uh killing
premeditated a baby came and premeditate
when it's going to use the bathroom but
come on
bro I want you I want you to think about
this like in in the Quran Allah tells us
about
now we're told about things like the
fruit that's going to be in Jannah
but it's not actually going to be the
fruit
it's just something that we can grasp
with our limited understanding so what
if
what if the description of the Hellfire
it's just something that we can
understand with our limited
understanding but it's actually far
worse than this
hey bro I woke up from a nightmare
last night
and whatever like
I was just thinking like man what if
someone goes to jahannam and it's just
them like constantly repeating their
nightmares like they wake up from a
nightmare only to be in another
nightmare in another nightmare and
another nightmare like bro
that's pretty damn terrifying if you
think about it and even an atheist can
agree to that
being burned alive that's pretty damn
terrifying if you think about it even
the atheists can agree to that so I was
like now we go back to and I I've been
wanting to bring it to this but it's
like that who was it bro the Sheikh or
someone that said that uh one of the
atheists was like oh like how are you
gonna feel when uh you die and you find
out that everything you believed in was
a fake
and he was like oh I'm gonna feel a hell
of a lot better than you do when you
wake up after you die and you realize it
was all real
absolutely
and um the fact and I think the worst
trait somebody could have is is
arrogance because not only is he is he
ignorant but he's ignorant and he's
arrogant about it and this is not me
insulting him let me Define what I mean
he does not know what he's talking about
but he thinks he does
that's the worst quality you could have
in a person in any in any given subject
imagine I confidently walked in the room
and I'm just debating and arguing about
how one one plus one equals three and
I'm just arguing and arguing no one plus
one equals three I'm sorry I'm arrogant
and I'm ignorant and I'm not having any
kind of beneficial discussion because
it's not possible with those two
qualities and what's my reason for
saying this
it's because of the answer he had when
Mike proposed a very fair philosophical
wager which is called I think Pascal's
wager which is you might as well just
believe in God because if there's a
chance that God exists and you know you
would go to hell and be punished for not
believing in him then you should you
know not wager that and just say I
believe in God and believe that he
exists and that he's watching over all
of us and that stuff you know
that's a fair thing but what was Logan's
response I'm right I'm not wrong I'm not
how do you know can you produce one
argument please please for anyone
produce one argument that proves that
God does not exist there should not be
one logical or intellectual atheists in
the world and Atheism was honestly the
biggest lie in recent history
academically speaking it's the biggest
lie because people like Richard Dawkins
have went on record saying that he knows
he can't disprove God but people think
if I prove Evolution I disprove God and
that's why it's because it's become this
Darwinism versus God weird thing where
you could have a world where God created
Darwinism and and this Evolution and
this evolutionary uh train obviously
it's not fully compatible with Islam and
that's not a problem it's even from a
scientific perspective it's not a
problem but if I'm a completely theistic
theistic perspective God could have
created Darwinism and and that other
evolutionary chain it wouldn't be a
problem
right so this is intellectual arrogance
that atheists have they have some kind
of you know not only intellectual
superiority which is very funny given
what I just mentioned but a moral
superiority now why is this funny
why is it funny that atheists have this
this weird moral superiority
because atheism leads to moral nihilism
because you cannot prove what is right
what is wrong objectively at least
George can say I believe theft is wrong
because it's in the Bible and God that's
what God decreed it so it's objectively
true okay Muslims would say the same
thing or something similar
what is Logan gonna say oh I believe I
believe it's wrong because my daddy said
so I believe it's wrong because everyone
else says it's wrong
there's no objective standing for him
and I think that's that's the oddest
part because he's deluded in his own his
own atheism yeah and the problem with
subjective morality bro is the goal
posts are going to be constantly
changing rule 24 7. just look at history
look at the last couple years decades
things that were not legal in the west
alone are illegal things that were
illegal are now legal and promoted
absolutely absolutely
I just want to give some sincere
advice
whether they receive it from my words or
the words of someone else that
it's in Allah's hands
but to both of you but it's
um what's the ones the the one that had
the Jackie this Christian what's his
name George George my sincere advice
is to exercise your boundaries and
understand like
basically who you are and like where you
stand right like you have to have
friends even with your friends you have
to have fun
like if I ask you all right now when I'm
hanging out with y'all do I have a
friend
of course but there are times where I
break frame and I'm just laughing
enjoying myself
it doesn't mean that I have to be like
I'm trying to be like Daddy you're alpha
or anything like that around you guys it
just means like look this is this is
what I stand for like don't don't cross
these boundaries and we'll be good
that's cool that's it you guys have done
this I don't cross without you simple as
that
and it's the the quicker you do this the
more respect the more respect you will
enforce and demand without even trying
to say anything or do anything
and then for for Logan Paul Paul Logan
or Paul Paul that's his name right Logan
Paul Logan Paul Paul Logan what the hell
am I saying Logan bro
it's a lot bro
to love honestly if I just chill out
really are you really going to chill out
man
if there's one thing that I've learned
from my my experience and from others is
that when we are arrogant especially
like this
well it never ends good
usually ends with like something that's
really important to you in your life
being stripped away from you
so I don't want to see that happen to
you I don't want to see that happen to
anyone
so just sincere advice man just chill
out
behalf
yeah please go on I was just gonna say
if I don't know on this because I know
we have to move on but
I think it's very possible because with
a lot of atheists they're not you know
they're not atheists because of uh their
intellect or because of logic or
rationality it's usually just because of
an emotional reason even if they they
put on the surface as a logical it's
rational it's whatever there's no
evidence of all this stuff even if they
throw that on the surface usually it's
an emotional thing so I want to be
shocked if if Logan's had like an
emotional roundabout with God and he's
been asking God for some things and you
know he didn't get it and it was a very
dire time so he just came to conclusion
well God must not exist or if he does he
hates me and you know all these is very
sad and you know thoughts that Satan
would come and Whisper to a person
so I I hope that's Insha'Allah
he can open his heart up enough to have
a discussion wholesomely with uh with us
or with other Muslims because obviously
you know we don't fully agree with
George although we we agree generally
with the things we're saying in this
video
um he should open up you know his heart
to the idea of God believing in God and
uh ask that you know God God guides him
to the truth insha Allah
inshallah I mean all right we're gonna
blast through these super chats insha
Allah and then bring on the lovely
brother who wants to convert to Islam
and accept the truth tonight with us
live inshallah uh guys please smash that
like button guys it really helps our
Channel helps produce our content and
push these videos out to more people to
find Islam inshallah
Samurai spaghetti and meatballs
I guess sure it is enough thank you
Anthony Wright's Angel got me all hot
and bothered now but facts show respect
to Islam
I mean bro I love it but
then do you guys want to read that out
Islam does not promote going into
forests and recording dead people
SMH may Allah guide him also love your
channel y'all are intelligent folks you
guys remember when Logan Paul had that
thing in the forest bro yeah yeah that's
why this is so sad because he had like a
um kind of a Redemption Arc and it's
like slowly he's been getting worse and
worse but
you know what I thought was crazy it
just like came back into my mind where
they were talking about like the Father
the Holy Spirit and the son the son
and he was saying that like oh you can
disrespect all of them except the Holy
Spirit say oh hold up aren't they all
the same
but not even that you could disrespect
God and not the Holy Spirit bro
bro wait if if if they're all the same
if they're all the same they're all one
then if you disrespect the Holy Spirit
you're disrespecting the father and the
son ah bro that's again bro it don't
make sense yeah and can you imagine can
you imagine someone going up to Jesus
and disrespecting the father
what what do you think Jesus would say
to someone like that bro come on
we love eastern time
um but yeah uh there was another Super
Chat that I didn't get to read from the
from the same person
throw it up oh here
yeah I also want to thank uh you for
everything you do thanks to your channel
I've gotten the cursory where the hijab
operation belongs to Allah alhamdulillah
may Allah reward you because all good is
from Allah
brother the link and he is here what's
going on all right
how's it going bro it's all good
all right can you hear as well yeah I
can hear you guys all right all right
all right beautiful bro so you want to
give the viewers a quick little
introduction on why you reached out to
us uh I think a few days ago
yeah so the reason I reached out to you
guys is because like I said I was doing
a whole bunch of research on Islam man
so after Andrew take converted to Islam
I went and did my own research I found
your guys's YouTube channel watching a
whole bunch of videos I fell in love and
I was like yeah I do need to get on this
stream I do need to talk to these guys I
want some more insight about Islam and I
want to go ahead and convert and make my
journey man
may God bless you bro
you said that you you were following
Andrew Tate's stuff and then you saw him
become a Muslim yeah and then they got
you curious yeah that got me curious
because well the crazy part about my
story is my dad was Muslim too but at
the same time my mom and my dad
separated right oh I got you yeah so my
mom my dad separated
like after Andrew Tate when he converted
I was like let me actually take as I'm
an adult now let me actually take a look
back in the Islam and see what it's
talking about and everything and yeah
man it's the truth like after reading it
I'm in love man
that is beautiful that's beautiful very
beautiful so please bro please go into
your story start from scratch man we got
we got all the time in the world and and
tell us where you are today if you have
any questions we'll try to answer them
along the way all right yeah so
basically my story starts off man so I
started off staying in like I'm in the
I'm in the US so for everybody needs to
know that I'm in the U.S I started off
staying in Georgia and then after that
my mom my dad you know you know how
sometimes relationships don't work out
and everything like that so they end up
separating everything but when I was a
kid we did go to the mosque we did pray
and all that but after I got like after
I got separated with my mom and
everything like that she was Christian
we started going to church so that's all
I knew so but I really wasn't too like
accepting of it but that was just all I
knew from you know being with my mom and
everything like that so I mean I always
been fond of doing YouTube and stuff
like that too so I got back into doing
content creation and everything like
that so
on that journey I finally agitate
agitate like he basically I know I know
everybody knows about him man bless the
brother man but at the same time the
life he was living before was kind of
degenerate and for him with all that
money and everything like that and all
the accomplishment stuff he had to
accept Islam I was like that is crazy
like that's crazy so I had to do my own
research and everything led me to
reading the Quran man I got one right
here man let it read let me to read the
Quran maybe they're making a tick tock
about my Islamic content and everything
like that and a lot of people have been
actually reaching out to me and saying a
lot of positive things about him so I
mean it just it's been it's been a
journey man and I think this is the next
step man and
it's a
H
all right very very beautiful so you
mentioned you have some questions you
want to ask yourself Mercer afterwards
yeah I can ask I can ask them now all
right let's go for it so isn't one of
you guys a revert I want to ask you guys
um why did y'all accept Islam yeah I'm
I'm the only reason are you on the river
yeah yeah but no these these sort of
they're kind of reverts In Their Own no
way too okay every born Muslim that
comes back to Islam I mean I would say
uh but realistically I guess
I guess I am the only like actual reason
yeah uh but man
I'll keep it very simple because I I
want the spotlight to be on Hugo and
right it's it's amazing but I accepted
Islam bro because I just
I was at the lowest point of my life
yeah
and when I was at the lowest point in my
life looking for all these distractions
no one around me
I decided to do like a dopamine detox
cut everything out and I started feeling
this pool to read the Quran and once I
started reading the Quran
it's just like I would reflect on it and
by the third day of reading it it's like
it all just clicked yeah when it all
clicked I felt these like waves going
through my body and I was like oh
oh that's different yeah and I hit a
fire and I was like fire bro like I was
reading the Quran and um yeah I had
these like waves going through my body
he said oh bro you're a Muslim
and I was like whoa whoa relax bro relax
like what do you mean I'm a Muslim and
they started telling me everything and
then it just kind of happened from there
bro oh okay
yeah that's good like that's exactly
kind of how I felt as soon as I started
reading the Quran I was just I couldn't
put it down like so I started I could
have put down this like because like one
thing about me I like to seek the truth
and I'm Gonna Keep I'm gonna keep
digging to keep searching until I find
the truth and I think I think I think
Islam is it so another thing I do want
to ask you guys okay about
um what's the main key differences from
Christianity to Islam because I know I
know for example um you know Prophet
Jesus it's kind of different now I know
people have been telling me that like
how how like they they were saying like
in Christianity how Jesus um life's
ended is different than how this Islam
so I want you guys to brush up on that
so I can yeah absolutely you know
actually bro it's amazing well it's
beautiful because I was I was talking to
my brother about this today and I was
telling him no other way of life makes
sense except for Islam and I was talking
about the different ways atheism
Christianity all that stuff and when I
got to Christianity you know I it just
it became so clear to me that
it does not matter whatever people say
about Jesus and how he died from a seven
perspective yeah because Jesus was not
sent for us so it really doesn't matter
why why does it matter how he passed
away whatever to you living the 21st
century yeah himself in in what we have
the Bible today you know we don't think
it's fully authentic but for a Christian
who believes in the Bible as a sense
today what does it say Jesus said I came
for No One except the lost sheep of the
children of Israel right so what is he
gonna do for you know for random
Gentiles living in the 21st century from
our perspective he didn't even come for
us so it doesn't really matter because
we know Islam is the truth you know kind
of regardless of what Paul said and
these other people who we actually don't
even know who they are today you know a
lot of the books were written in Austin
or the gospels yeah but um the main
difference is like in terms of creed and
theology is the belief in the Trinity
you know obviously not reconcilable one
with human logic two with the basic idea
of God or three with Islam and lastly
making Jesus to be a Divine figure
um he's a prophet messenger and Messiah
yeah but he's not God and nor does that
make sense for a person for a human to
be God is that actually the question
yeah it does it does but to add on to
that too like what happens in Judgment
Day like so this does Jesus come back I
heard somebody was saying something
about that yeah so as Muslims in this
life we believe that Jesus will have a
second coming right because we believe
that God what happened is instead of
letting the people kill him right he
raised him up to himself and then he
will bring him back before the day of
judgment towards the end times he will
kill the Antichrist and he will be with
the Muslims with the people right and uh
basically and and call them towards
goodness and that stuff and actually
it's narrated it would be a very
beautiful very very beautiful time where
there would be no Injustice in that
stuff on the Earth yeah and I want you
to imagine bro like look at look at the
honor that Allah that God has given
Prophet Jesus peace be upon him to
destroy the Antichrist look at how
powerful that is and then I want you to
also compare that to how a lot of like
Christian Media and Netflix how they're
portraying Jesus to be like the soft
weak figure you know yeah it's a stark
contrast
that's a good point
yeah
yeah that does make sense to me also
um do you guys all know fluent Arabic
yeah the only I know flu Arabic yeah I
want to know that yeah I wanted to know
that we're learning okay
yeah so another thing too like as far as
like the prayers and stuff like that
it's five prayers right so if you are
you are praying could you pray in
English until you learn it in Arabic how
does that work so
the I guess the the bad news for some
reason that you you can't pray in
English yeah but but let me give you the
good news the good news is the most
forgiving the most merciful so if you're
learning uh you know which by the way
there are reverts who memorize and learn
how to pray literally in a day and
suddenly take a week or a little bit
longer we'll learn it literally in no
time yeah
um and Allah will have mercy and forgive
those who are you know learning how to
pray but just don't fully know yet so
you'll be there very simple don't worry
okay yeah and
honestly man like a lot of people would
try to tell you like the the right way
to do this and this is the wrong way
yeah listen
for myself bro
from us although this person really
donate 99
.
listen bro like when I first started
I I actually put the um this guy
reciting Surah Fatiha and like going
through the motions like on my phone and
I would just watch him and like follow
along and like go with the prayer right
and just listen I didn't even know how
to recite it yeah so like we all learned
how we came right and again like Allah
is the most forgiving so he understands
exactly yeah where you are in your
journey yeah and exactly what you need
to do in order to like keep progressing
right yeah
okay another question I have so what's
the biggest Lifestyle Changes coming
from like Christianity Islamic I know is
they praying five times a day and like
it's certain things that are Haram that
a lot of the stuff that go on in the
west is around so yeah yeah I know like
for one thing to another thing like
relationships like that can't do that
you can't do that you need to you need
to get married and everything like that
so I want you guys to brush up on that
maybe like some of the things that like
are Haram to keep things out Haram for
men to do in Islam okay so first thing I
wanted to say is is uh kind of love bro
we had this another Andrew Tate fan that
came on the channel converted to Islam
we did a whole live like shahada he
asked us or asked me a lot of questions
about Islam and him and a lot of these
people that are coming to slum one of
the most common questions they ask is
how do we navigate relationships and
marriage and all that yeah so I think it
would be it would be suitable none other
than Angel who is a river himself to
kind of talk about how his view on
relationships has changed how it's a
little bit more easy in some ways a
little bit difficult in other ways right
I mean
I was just going to say one point and
let y'all say like another point but I
could speak about that if you want
uh with relationships man like
I'm coming from straight degeneracy
before Islam bro like I'm not gonna lie
to you I'm not gonna try to Sugar Cody
yeah
um I was I was actively trying to talk
to many women but
because in 2018
okay I was actually engaged I was not
Muslim I was Christian kind of actually
yeah I was Christian I was Christian
I was Christian I was engaged as
Christian woman and then 2018
she ended up leaving me wow now this bro
this was like a pivotal point because
for me
um it was it was very hard I'm not gonna
lie it was very hard yeah and in that
moment it's like I can't say I was close
to God yeah but I knew I knew like okay
I have to stop talking to women for some
time because clearly there's something
wrong yeah like with me not not her or
like the whole relationship like sure
she had her problems too but I'm saying
with me there's something wrong here so
I think I spent like a year in something
well I was just completely celebrate not
talking to any woman whatsoever and then
it's like after that I started trying to
actively look for him and not getting
Allah's the best planners none of that
worked out right it's like a lot kept me
celibate so that I could learn so I
could actually grow and heal from
everything and then when I became Muslim
then Allah like made everything clear to
me it's like look this is why you know
this was going here this is why this
didn't happen here and this is why this
he was basically preparing me for this
because
had I experienced the degeneracy before
going into Islam maybe that might not
have been the best thing for me yeah but
I know that when I came into Islam like
it was very it was very understandable
like oh yeah you don't actually have
relations with a woman before you get
married because if you do
it blinds you to the red flags yeah that
could possibly be there right
exactly though so I mean for me that was
like the biggest thing in terms of
relationships
um but the biggest thing that I wanted
to say like I'd say the biggest change
that I've been singing or that I had to
make in my lifestyle
was um
just constantly constantly going to a
law rule yeah definitely going to God
yeah
could I not to bash any Christian
anything like that but that was one
thing that I didn't like it was because
most Christians that I knew they only
went to God when when they needed
something it was never a thing to where
that you call on the law all the time it
was never that it was never that yeah
and that's it man that's Super Bowl
for me there's way more bullet I want to
keep it simple I wanted to let the other
brothers be here yeah and I wanted to
touch on this beautiful point there that
as Muslims we're not shy from intimacy
bro we don't have any weird rules like
you want to get up in the church you got
to devote yourself to God you're
celibate none of this man-made stuff you
can have one wife and if you can treat
them equal you can have more than one
wife right up to four right
um but the main message is we're not shy
from intimacy the prophet peace be upon
him he went to the youth you know the
shabab and he told them that all of you
guys if you have the ability to get
married get married you know but if you
can't then fast
um so in Islam we're not shy about
marriage or intimacy or anything like
that but we have a permissible way and
then obviously a non-impermissible way
right so that's really it bro so the
advice is obviously if you can get
married to get married
um but that's all I'm gonna say bro and
let me actually slide back in here
yeah bro when you when you are
worshiping Allah and you are getting
closer and closer to Allah right
and he puts a woman in your life
that is almost like a direct reflection
of you like y'all are on the same level
y'all both growing and y'all like on the
same y'all been leveling up y'all at the
same level right bro it's something else
like nothing no other woman that I've
ever met in my life yeah compares to my
wife right now bro right and that's
that's a beautiful thing bro and again
like I do not believe that I could have
ever experienced this had I not been
Muslim had I not been getting closer to
Allah yeah
yeah that does make sense man that makes
a lot of sense and that's all I'm
starting to see man the more the more
information I get the more it makes
sense to me and I mean if y'all have
nothing else for me I think I'm ready
and let me let me ask you a quick
question bro are you single yeah
yeah there's there's a lot of technical
a little bit more techy cases when you
when you deal with Christians you know
let's say they accept Islam they become
Muslim they open their eyes to the truth
right but let's say they're married they
have a wife so now you know we got to
give dollar to the wife uh they gotta
and inshallah become Muslim and then you
know you guys get married but for you
it's it's almost a blessing that you are
single so it's just you and now you can
worry about you know finding the other
half inshallah yeah yeah absolutely
inshallah so just before we get started
first I want to give a brief note for
myself it's I want to say first for us
it's beautiful that you're already
concerned with what is Haram yeah and I
want you to as you learn about these
things after you become Muslim you start
practicing I want you to First learn
about why these things are important
right you know why should you be
concerned with what's Halal right you
know these these beliefs are fundamental
you know oh God God says this is halal
this is Haram why do I obey God in these
regards right it's because God is all
knowing god is all wise he created you
and me the universe and life and death
to test who is good indeed we know that
anything God tells us to do is good and
anything God tells us not to do that
thing would have been bad for us and
understanding those things makes it a
lot easier to understand you know and
why you're doing them why you're
avoiding them and it makes it easier to
practice those things right so
with that being said I have to ask you
some questions just so we know that you
know you understand Islam correctly
nobody's misinformed you and all that
stuff okay so and they're really simple
though I'm not going to give you your
questions I promise okay so do you
believe that there's one God worthy of
worship with no Partners or Associates
or Sons or daughters yes perfect do you
believe in the Angels yes do you believe
in the prophets and Messengers that God
sent yes do you believe in the books and
the Revelation that God has sent with
His prophets and Messengers yes do you
believe in destiny that God has a Divine
Destiny for all of us yes and do you
believe in the day of judgment yes
perfect do you believe that the Quran is
the unchanged word of Allah yes I do
perfect
and with that being said you're going to
inshallah repeat after me first I wanna
I wanna ask you guys
if
if you if you want to do it this way
so can you guys see my screen right now
yeah
so I can highlight the word so you can
see them as we say them do you want to
do it that way yeah yeah no worries okay
so just repeat after me a shadow a
shadow
Ella
ilaha illallah
Anna Anna
Muhammad Muhammad rasul rasul Allah
Allah
now just repeat after me in English I
bear witness I bear witness that there
is none worthy of worship that there is
now worthy of worship except for Allah
except for Allah and I bear witness and
our bear witness that the prophet
Muhammad that the prophet Muhammad is
the final messenger and prophet of God
it's a fan of messenger and prophet of
God
you are now our brother in Islam and
everybody warm welcome to our brother in
Islam may Allah bless them we already
have it feel good boy
feel good
that's what's up man may Allah bless you
bro it's it's gonna feel
it's gonna feel different this next
month that's all I got to tell you yeah
yeah
uh sveno someone made such a beautiful
point in the chat
let me find it the Allahu Akbar is
coming so fast bro it instantly
disappeared but they say wiped clean of
all his sins and given Good Deeds for
them subhanallah when a person accepts
Islam Allah forgives them for all of
their bad deeds and their sins of the
past and let them keep their Good Deeds
what does this mean
this means that any Muslim who is sinful
you know and has good deeds and whatever
but they have sins our brother might be
a lot better than them right now because
he has no sins on his plate no one's on
his plate and only good deeds is
beautiful yeah so what does what does
what what you know should life look like
now what should our outlook on life be
some people have this perspective you
don't seem like the type so it's not
about you but some people have the
perspective and the thought that oh once
I accept Islam uh my life is gonna be
easy peasy God loves me I'm good what
does Allah say in the Quran Allah says
that he created death and life to test
which one of us
or you know the ones who are good
indeeds Allah is going to test us we're
going to be tested with good times and
we're going to be tested with bad times
it's possible that you walk into the
next step of life and it's an adversity
where God is testing you
it's possible that you're a Muslim for
10 years and then God decides to test
you with something difficult but what
did the prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings of Allah be upon him say
he said how amazing is the state of a
Muslim how amazing is the state of a
Muslim because when he's tested with
something that's good he is thankful to
God and that is better for him
but when he's tested with something
difficult
he is patient and that is better for him
because God will test the person and
there's another Hadith that says that
Allah will test the person because he
Wills for them goodness and he wants to
raise them in ranks and you would not
have gotten to this point you know
leveling up to this point in this life
or and in the next unless God tests you
and I want to speak on my own behalf
right now
where I am now with whatever goodness I
have alhamdulillah with whatever I know
or my character or whatever financially
and being married all that stuff
alhamdulillah all of it every single
ounce of it not only does it come from
Allah but it has come from Allah and
Allah blessed me with these things
through a difficulty through a hardship
and it's only been through these
hardships but Allah has really blessed
me in this life and I think many many
brothers and sisters can say the same
thing about them and their lives
so the main focus for us is that we
worship Allah alone
and we submit to him and brother
inshallah we're going to stay in contact
we're going to say don't worry it's not
going to be like a shahada and go you
are our brother in Islam now you are sha
Allah at the moment being the fourth
Muslim here alhamdulillah
yeah yeah I do I want to do want to do
this again sometimes because I'm still
going to be making content and
everything like that and I know these
people want me to talk more about Islam
and now they want to see my journey now
so I'm definitely I definitely want to
keep in contact with you guys
we're here my man we're here for my
brother
all right well thank you all so much man
how many how many lives I gotta got a
long journey ahead
what what's your Instagram what's your
Instagram I want to send you a deal uh
she'd underscore four five six I'll just
I'll make a group chat bro with all of
us yeah make a group chat yeah yeah oh
bro something I want to see you
you might start getting a lot of Muslims
like sending you a lot of message yeah
that's beautiful exactly yeah bro may
Allah bless them for the intention but
you're probably gonna get even more now
yeah it's gonna be them trying to like
tell you what to do now they just become
Muslim they all have good intentions
but it's gonna be right now like it's
very easy to get overwhelmed yeah yeah
so just take your time yeah take it
little by little baby steps here bro
Allah loves what is done
consistently even if it's like the
smallest thing but just consistently
Allah loves that consistency bro right
all right boys I just made a group chat
all right all right beautiful
alhamdulillah all right my brother
inshallah will connect offline may Allah
bless you immensely all right y'all
everybody be safe man I hope you all
enjoy the rest of y'all day and thank
y'all so much man got a long journey
ahead all right
what a beautiful brother man honestly
everyone made God for him and uh send
only positive messages to the brother
inshallah
please guys keep keep us all in the
doors
any advice for a person working at Haram
job listen bro the fact that you're
calling the job Haram is is saying that
I have to leave it so what advice can I
give other than what we're taught to
leave the job Allah will give you that
which is better
mm-hmm
alhamdulillah man
I just want to end the broadcast and let
go pray man like that was so beautiful
I just want to go make it
so that's nice Allah you know like he
blessed us with that this is beautiful
that Allah blesses us with this with
these opportunities may Allah forgive us
and accept it from us I mean well I mean
huh
like when you see people reverse it
always reminds you
yeah it reminds you like that you're not
crazy
yeah like it's actually real you know
and it's not saying that we ever like
doubt it but it's like the worst ones
it's always there and like sometimes
like Mom wavers and then when we see
someone else except Islam and we see
like they're just so on it
it just reawakens it
it like brings you right back to like
that that state where you're like ah
yeah like you know what like this is
real
right here
foreign
multitudes of the religion of Allah and
multitudes
um then basically praise Allah and seek
his forgiveness indeed Allah
um
indeed Allah is ever forgiving of of
Toba and repentance so let us do that
now inshallah
um all thanks and all praise to Allah
who facilitated this for us and for you
guys and allowed us to be guided to the
truth of Islam and allowed us to be one
ummah one community
blessed with such a beautiful Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam The Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings of Allah be
upon him as a perfect example and God
for us in this life and he will be an
intercessor for us in the next so
remember when you hear the name across
the son say peace and blessings be upon
him and thank Allah for blessing us with
Islam and seek forgiveness from him and
not to remind you to myself first and
foremost and to everyone in here
inshallah as well
and let's just take a second let's take
a second to
say masha'allah to that beautiful beard
that Romy has developed over the course
of two years
may Allah make it even more thicker than
it already is boy
um
and to anyone that made it here guys
stay tuned till March
2023 or biggest guest that we're ever
going to bring in show alone this
podcast we all accepted from us and make
a beneficial discussion for them I mean
I mean
and with that being said